le premier talent on le surnomme le
calculateur
c'est jean luc lemoine
un peu d'histoire
[Applaudissements]
l'installation prise vous savez n'est en
fait vous avez deux talents mais ouais
je suis là je suis dans ses calculs
c'est pas de moi je sais pas si je
comprend pas le projet jean-luc je vous
propose est ce que jean luc et venir
côté parce qu'on voit pas bien fait mais
je sais bien c'est bien mais là c'est
pas bien parce qu'on le voit pas on ne
voit pas de face
alors jean luc bonnet près de moi jean
luc viaux p2p disent ah oui jusqu'au
toit jean-luc il a un talent
exceptionnel je vous jure c'est vrai
c'est une technologie de préciser je ne
vais pas garder la surprise pour que tu
es b c est parce que j brody que vous a
dit un truc avons à faire de calculs
bien sûr jean luc azoulay dû composer
des calculs mentaux calcul mon attention
d'accord un exercice de calcul mental
pour jean-luc et vous allez voir qu'il
est excellent en moins de 5 secondes il
peut vous trouver des calculs très
difficile vous n'êtes pas le cas à je
t'aime beaucoup attention
par 25
par 8 - 794 16 par 25 par mois
784 je vous jure qu'il n'a pas
d'oreillette 2406 ces jeunes 1406 c'est
la bonne réponse doit rajouter
attention deuxième quel qu en soit la
143 milles 0,69
il est dur / / 79 143 milles 0,69 / 79
ça c'est impossible
143 milles 0,69 1811
non c'est pas possible je vous jure que
c'est 1811 je vous jure que c'est vrai
mais je pense aussi c'est papa aussi
être regardés non mais jean-luc non mais
à voir après la réponse est non non non
je vous jure et si sa bosse et moi
confiance était mon producteur
non mais je vous jure que ça n'est pas
truqué ses toiles attention derniers
calculs 12 au carré par 12 plus 1212
moins deux fois 12 - 12 par 2 12 au
carré x 12 plus 1212 moins deux fois
12.12 par deux vous dit ça va parmi les
origines d'action de 1910
c'est un truc c'est de 1910 2009 110 ch
vous jure que c'est la bonne réponse et
chez vous êtes vous
et ça n'est pas truquée excellent moi
dans mon chat lui